hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master Chamberlain from Russia mr.
Gavriel off right yep Jackie I remember
recently losing a game against him I
don't remember details but it wasn't it
wasn't funny what I remember check yeah
this is an interesting life that I had
this on the board in ER in a tournament
game against Grandmaster Alex Landerman
only short while ago oh well short while
ago about one and half years ago and now
they opened the variant championships
and I thought that was a good game boy
that's a good game it was a good line
well worth repeating Bishop g4 he
probably who retreated sin I John right
age for I have discoveries I think yeah
so he goes back how it goes six and back
here yeah I was my attention was be five
but not totally sure about it I want to
do this right it's not totally clear I
won't want to do it this is this is not
bad at all
trying to operate with Queen to be six
yeah I now be five is it's good I think
yeah I'm attacking this with night a six
um question is right now or later I
think I'll do it right away and queso
and stick now and we're going to be
seven and then double on there on the C
file okay I wonder at f/4 is coming but
it doesn't seem to be he seems to be
very much poised to play on the
queenside
I'm just I just want to be ready for any
F form even though it feels unlikely
that he plays it the way he set up his
pieces up to this point yes to take with
a queen right over the night okay yeah
at least in a way that I should be okay
on the C file
hmm yeah I wonder if I'm able to do
something more actively some f5 on
probably not
don't see anything anything active in
this position
trying to enter with the rook yeah I
don't know I don't see anything right we
also don't see anything great for him
but
want to keep the a file the a file open
can I don't know should I trade treaty
or not and maybe not but after the Queen
trade I see some ideas f5 stuff okay I
think this cannot be bad
so equal time I don't know what is he
doing I want I would like to get in at
5am
oh he wants to try to trap my Ruca shoot
i forgot about this idea completely damn
i know there was a totally safe position
and I overlooked this idea I just have
to go back with a book instead oh my god
okay night a success the only move that
might work threatening night before and
have some some tactical ideas here maybe
this so works yeah maybe a test so takes
bishop good night takes and two check
check I always hate those totally
unnecessary things where you immediately
see what kind of nonsense you have
played it'sit's such as so easy and just
so easy okay I kindly take five now
actually check this is quite okay now
right yeah it's very ok
it was a lucky miss he didn't didn't see
that I guess
yeah I will win some points now or maybe
you place book takes before word that
should lose
just try to play it simple him chick
she doesn't help that much maybe go back
check check so anything great that he
can do check this is I wanted to go back
actually that was a check pretty all I
didn't want it hi it was a long time yet
yeah I totally didn't see that that trap
idea I think we we had a pretty this
position is roughly equal I think if
anybody Wyatt is better a little bit but
don't think I should lose and yeah I
mean this was okay for the time being
what I should spot the idea that this
rook might be trapped so here I should
just go back yeah and play this position
so like back and something like this and
I mean okay I think it's about equal
knight c6 maybe White has still not
something the engine also says 0.4 yeah
it's a bit better but I totally did not
see this and now I'm probably in trouble
night a6 seemed like the only try to me
but he has not be seven
hmm that's very bad I have to do this
then then you can take it easily I can
win Twins and here check I've also in
trouble but you should go here I can do
this jack but this is falling check yeah
you just plug that this you should take
here kinky free already is a mistake but
this is still check okay according to
the comp that's a super-sharp ending
with the beep own and bow and I've jack
after this I am all the Sun winning III
it was strong okay yeah I kind of knew
that I would win on time so and this is
cam chat sometimes influencing a little
bit that you don't look that hard
anymore yeah it was i was a tricky game
when i was in trouble okay thanks for
watching